[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul AKA Ryan Seacrest
Invasion and this video we're talking
about what's going on with Everett Ross
heavy straight Off heavy spoilers ahead
for secret Invasion so if you haven't
had a chance to check out episode 1 then
check out now everything from this point
onwards is gonna ruin the episode for
you and staying past this point would be
a weird hell to die on oops spoiling
already with the puns but yeah we have a
lot to talk about now the episode opens
with Everett Ross meeting a crazy
conspiracy theorist that we learned
named agent Prescott finding out that he
has damning evidence of Scrolls plans
Prescott lashes out at him which is when
he's killed by the character Ross runs
off into the night pursued by a shadowy
figure and it's from this point that it
all hits the fan he smashes the ground
like it's the like button and it's
revealed that he's a scroll and chances
are that this completely blew your mind
now I used to be like you not not a
chump like you but still someone who
didn't know what was going on however
the more I thought about it the more
it's become clear and I think I can
finally answer what's going on here but
I'm not a rapper everyone's obviously
asking if he's been a scroll the whole
time but there's actually a lot of clues
that show this isn't the case now in
order to talk about this I have to go
into the scroll imitation ritual like we
see being carried out in the episode
this happens in the restricted area of
the power plan in which we see a warrior
copying one of the anti-russian
Americans now in order to imitate
someone a scroll has to first see them
and this then allows them to duplicate
their look this was first shown in
Captain Marvel when Talus arrived on the
beach and he and his forces looked over
and two of them mimicked a surfer they
had to see her in order to do this and
this shows that Scrolls imitate by sight
it's the same with the soldier here and
the Scrolls have to make eye contact
with them so they can become a copy this
just gives them a better frame of
reference and it's like when you're an
artist and you use summing their base
you work off so Russ at some point would
have had to have been a real person so
that the scroll could copy them in the
first place sure they could have copied
him as a kid and then grown up as him
but at some point they'd have to work
their way through the security sector in
order to get to the top it's far easier
to copy someone who's already in that
position instead of playing the person
since birth so you can get into it now
Ross would be the perfect Target for a
scroll to imitate as well and it means
that they could just take a shortcut
when they're copying his look firstly he
was high up in American Security and
also married to Val who herself a big
name too add to this the fact that he
also hadn't in with wakanda and this
would make him an extremely valuable
Target this is a guy who's had his hand
in two of the most powerful countries on
Earth unless I think they sort him out
rather than a scroll growing up as him
now Ross has also done something
recently that makes him a very valuable
asset core giving secrets to wakanda he
was arrested by Val and then caught off
to prison for the rest of his life
despite know before he got there he was
freed by a Kaye and it's from here that
he likely had to lie low now this would
provide the scrolls with the perfect
opportunity to grab him as he's in a
very vulnerable position and out there
on his own he can't turn to the CIA
because they're out there after him
unless he couldn't go to them for help
if he found out he'd been copied he can
however eventually go to Shield but it's
unlikely that he would do that because
he's just been sprung from jail however
a scroll wouldn't have any qualms about
this and they may have captured him and
then took him into the plant copying him
from this point is the perfect point to
take over and this is something that
we've seen happen in the comics the
Scrolls tended to mimic someone when
they were completely on their own and at
a point where they could be swapped out
without anyone noticing they could have
seen that Ross was struggling on his own
and there's plenty of opportunity with
where we last left him now one of the
big weaknesses of the Scrolls is that
they're not perfect copies and they
often get sniffed out because of their
poor personalities not slagging you guys
off if you're watching it I'm show you
really nice and you always hit the
thumbs up button but it's something
that's happened to them throughout the
comics and movies scrolls are difficulty
copying mannerisms and under
interrogation they didn't hold up for
example we seen Captain Marvel how Talos
uses the wrong name with Nick and also
tries to Bluff his way through
conversations about their shared history
this is something that alerted Nick and
it often alerts the heroes in the comics
as skrulls couldn't really copy someone
down to that level now I will talk about
the machine they have in the show but I
doubt that a scroll would have copied
Ross back when he was giving Val his own
invasion in secret eh
now Val like Fury is someone who has
very few friends and she's immediately
suspicious of everyone she meets and the
car makes a scroll I actually took on
the form of Val and she and Fury ended
up spending the night together the next
day Fury was incredibly suspicious
because she'd done things he hadn't seen
before you know what I'm saying and he
followed her out there when she was
getting breakfast this took him to an
Alleyway where he saw her meeting a
contact and he instantly realized that
something was off back at their room he
then shot and killed her which is when
it was revealed that she was a scroll
now Val because of a job is exactly the
same as Fury in that she doesn't trust
anyone that's the thing that becoming
Ross would be the wrong thing for a
scroll to do and it would make things so
complicated if they were in a
relationship she'd probably sniff him
out and realize that something was off
and would likely be aware of the Scrolls
anyway because of her security clearance
so I can't see her Skrill imitating him
then and I think at the very least
they'd wait until they divorced we also
don't know what kind of mutants there
are knocking about on the MCU and in the
comics these could easily catch out
Scrolls Wolverine had a heightened sense
of smell so he could tell if someone was
faking it and Professor Rex could read
minds and deduce it from that as well
now again wakandas are highly Advanced
civilization too and they probably have
the tech to sniff out foreign entities
Shiri of course operated on Ross after
he got shot and it's likely she would
have discovered he was a scroll during
this time so it has to have happened
after that in order for things to work
and thus Ross couldn't have been one as
recently as that now I personally think
that he was likely grabbed after
escaping the van as he probably had to
make his way out of the US wanted in the
country he may have done in Edward
Snowden which would have probably taken
him all the way to Russia this would
allow the Scrolls the perfect chance to
grab him and they could then take over
him and go and work with shield now the
memory machines have also had some
upgrades too and we see them possessing
far more power than before they can now
hold someone in place and their Scrolls
can pull out their memories which will
help them fake people better when it
comes to these kinds of agents and out
Hill would have just let him in the
organization and he'd probably have had
to pass some tests to prove that it was
him having these memories though allowed
for him to work his way in and this is
why she seems so shocked when she sees
him on the ground she genuinely believed
that this was ever Ross and I was
surprised that her and fury didn't talk
about it at some point potentially
they're all just as confused as we are
but it was a weird Omission to not have
it brought up now the reason I think it
wasn't is because they're not that alarm
because they don't think that he's been
a scroll for this entire time Taos
probably fell them in and it means that
Ross is out there and likely still under
the capture of them now I do think at
some point that we will see him come
back and he's probably gonna be someone
they rescue in the show makes sense to
have some characters we care about being
held captive by the Scrolls as it'll add
more emotion to the rescue scene when
they're finally freed so in the end I
think the Scrolls became aware of agent
press God and as they send someone in
who could find out hour was going on
Ross seemed like the best fit and thus
he was then Chosen and this is when
Talos got wiser their plans at least
that's what I think when we talk about
that reveal it might be right might be
wrong but I love to hear your thoughts
on it in the comments below if you want
to support the channel for as little as
99 cents a month then please click the
join button below and as a thank you
you'll get early access to videos every
week we also have our merch store over
at shop zeroedition.com which sells lots
of nerdy inspired t-shirts hats and more
who just launched a secret Invasion
slash Pulp Fiction inspired t-shirt so
if you want to head over there and help
us out then the links in the description
now if you want something else to watch
then make sure you check out our
Brighton on screen now going over
everything in that first episode we talk
about which characters you can see in
the background that then sharp later on
and there's lots of cool little details
hidden away in the scenes hopefully I
see you over there after this if not
then don't care because you're clearly a
scroll I didn't want you hanging around
on the channel anyway so get that get
the hell out of here son of a
anyway thanks for sitting through it if
you if you're not a scroll and I'll see
you next time you take care I'm out
peace